yeah so let's see
mike works so it's great to have uh
prasad continuous series from yesterday
he'll tell us about some of squares
uh
hey everyone uh
my apologies i can't be there today um
there was a co-weight positive case this
morning in my son's daycare so
i guess it's not a good thing for me to
give a talk there in person but
i'm glad yesterday before the talk right
before the talk at noon i did one of the
home tests which the science institute
gives out um and i was negative
yesterday while i was in the talk so
that's good
um okay so let's uh start so today my
plan would be there are two lectures the
first lecture would mostly be about sum
of squares sdps um an application of
them and
in the second lecture i will talk more
about
barriers and open questions and i'll try
to sprinkle in open questions as i see
as we go
um okay so
we're going to do a very quick
introduction to sum of square sdps
so
the two three questions what do they do
we'll see what they do how how to use
them will be a
thing we'll focus on today and how they
work
uh maybe we'll if you have time we'll
talk about it but i doubt it okay so
let's see
what is sum of squares ep what do they
do
well this is what
happens so if you take a
degree d sum of squares relaxation
and
what it does is it takes as input a
polynomial system
so you
you give it as input a polynomial system
um so it's a bunch of inequalities p i
of x greater than or equal to 0 for i
equal to 1 through m
okay and in variables x 1 through x n so
there are n variables and there are m
inequalities or equalities in them
and we just give it to the system
and what it outputs it outputs a bunch
of numbers these numbers are supposed to
be
they're supposed to be
moments of a distribution
over solutions to this system
to the system p that we started with
okay and in particular what do i mean by
moments you know for every monomial if i
ask
x i squared x j x k
it will tell me what the expectation
of that monomial is
uh under this uh
distribution
so it's supposed to be moments of a
distribution over
solutions to this polynomial system so
it's the next best thing to actually
solving the system solving the system
would be you get a solution to the
system what you get here is just the
moments of an unknown distribution
well it's a little bit worse than that
in that these are
candidate moments in that
they're really pseudo moments
there might be no distribution that
actually has these moments
but this is what we get when we solve
the system
okay and these moments as i said it's a
number for every monomial
um
and
you know in order to
nicely
a notational thing to do is to
use all these numbers and define a
functional or polynomials so here's a
definition it's just a notational
simplification of course it's a very
powerful notational simplification uh
what what is it well you know we have
moments for every monomial which means
we can construct moments for every
polynomial so what what
the sos sdp gives us the degree ds vs
sdp it gives us a
functional
that can take any polynomial
in at most degree d
and gives out a real number it's a
linear functional
so this is just obtained by you know if
i know the moment of every monomial i
know the moment of every polynomial
which is just linear combination of that
okay but what does this satisfy well it
satisfies the following things
firstly it satisfies the polynomial
system that we gave it in so meaning of
e tilde of
p i of x
is greater than or equal to 0
for every constraint
that i had for every constraint that i
had in my polynomial system
its expectation or its pseudo
expectation is actually non-negative
and the second and the most important
thing is that pseudo expectation of any
square polynomial is non-negative
e tilde of
q squared of x
is greater than equal to zero for all
polynomials
degree of q less than d over 2.
so this is what we get so you feed it
any polynomial system it gives you a
pseudo expectation operator
[Music]
and the pseudoexpectation operator
satisfies these inequalities
okay
all right okay so that's good so now
okay so that's what they do so how do we
use them well uh to use them we
uh
you know
we will see how to use them by looking
at a particular application like an
example so the example that we look at
today is a
robust
linear regression
in particular i'm following this
paper work by
kothari clivens and mika
which i think is
probably the most uh
cleanest examples of sos sdp being used
and in fact you know
we can argue about it some time i
actually think it's much more
compelling
than government solutions in sdp but
yeah of course because government's sap
has a rounding set step which is
somewhat ad hoc which just comes out of
nowhere
but this is much
more principled
okay so here's what's happening okay
what's the problem is robust linear
regression we get a bunch of
training training examples uh where x i
is in r to the d
and a y i is in r okay it's a supervised
learning task so what is the but the
examples come in two categories
one minus epsilon n of them are good
points and epsilon n of them are bad
points
as you can imagine back points are just
arbitrarily address adversarial so they
just address area arbitrary
um
and the good points
are actually
um
of the following thing let's say they
have this following set up the setup is
a natural setup for linear regression so
what you have is x i
hat the
the example is a gaussian vector
okay and
the
label is actually labeled as per a real
and a good linear function
l hat in a product x i plus gamma i
where l hat is a linear function with
some bound on its known
okay and gamma i is some small noise
um you know
small gaussian noise let's say
um
and let's say
you know
you know let's say the noise is
of magnitude gamma or something
and of course what's the goal the goal
is to find
some linear function l star such that
its
cost on the good examples is small what
is a good example is basically it's the
examples from the set s
so if i look at expectation i from s
of the cost of that
linear function
this should be small okay that's our
goal
to find some linear function that fits
the good points we don't care about the
bad points
right is the the problem clear
okay
okay so
okay now we have this black box that
takes in a polynomial system so the
natural thing to do is to formulate our
problem as a polynomial system okay and
this is what we do so
what what are the variables of my
polynomial system well it's uh firstly
you have uh the linear function that you
want to find and calling it l one three
and d you know in ideal world this would
be the true linear function l hat
but
you know
those are the variables that stand for
that
and i guess the key distinction between
this robust problem and the usual linear
regression is the fact that for every
example i don't know if the example is a
good point or a bad point and somehow if
i knew which points were good i it would
be much more much easier problem so
really we need to have a variable that
tells us if a
point is actually a good point or a bad
point and so let's do write that so
wi is actually the indicator that
x i
is a good point
okay i mean of course that's the
intended
meaning of the variable wi uh we'll
write a polynomial system with these
this meaning
okay so now we start writing constraints
of the system so firstly wi is an
indicator it has to be boolean it has to
be 0 or 1. so you know the natural thing
is to say w i squared minus w i equal to
0.
okay the only solutions to this
are
w i being 0 or 1 so that's good okay and
then we want at least
a one minus epsilon n fraction the
points are good points right so that is
just saying
sum over i w i
is equal to one minus epsilon n
okay
okay and we have a bound on the actual
linear function that we're finding we
knew that the original linear function
had two norm less than one
right so let's just do the same thing
here let's just
write l squared is less than one
two norm squared
okay
and
finally what we really care about is the
error on the good points
okay so let's say the error on the good
points is we want it to be at most
i'm going to use epsilon again let me
say delta you want the error in the good
points to at most delta
so let me write that constraint
okay so what is how do i pick up just
the error on the good points well
i sum over all points
somewhere i equal to 1 through n
w i wi picks out only the good points
and then
y i minus
l inner product x i
whole square
okay so that is uh the that gives you
the error on the good points and you
know we want it to be on average less
than
f delta let's say one over n is less
than equal to delta
so that make sense
okay so
please talk me if you have any questions
um there is a question that was in the
chat i think julius asked why in
the second constraint is it an equality
is that without loss of generality ah
yeah yeah i think we could say without
loss of generality as in we could say
the sdp finds a linear function and one
minus epsilon n good points that fit
with it
yeah
um so that's why i put an equal you
could do most of i mean i think all of
the proof with an inequality also i'm
just keeping things simple here yeah
okay
okay
all right so um okay what do we do we
take this linear system and feed it into
our black box it gives us a
set of pseudo moments
okay
so let's say we use degree 8 sum of
squares as dp and you get a pseudo
expectation operator on degree 8
polynomials and
the polynomials you should remember are
on w i and l
we are writing polynomials in i mean
this
polynomial systems the variables are w i
and l uh
capital x i and
little y i
are actually
our data points that we got so we the
algorithm has them as numbers and of
course n and epsilon are all numbers
that are
there the
variables in the polynomial system are
really w i and l and you get a pseudo
expectation on that
okay just to remind you
all right so okay so this we got get a
whole bunch of these
expectations or pseudo expectations of
all of the monomials and the algorithm
is really simple algorithm is let's just
output
the
pseudoexpectation of the variables that
we care about which is l so you know
output
this vector
l star your output linear function
is e tilde of l 1
e tilde of l 2
e tilde of l d
but basically it's the z tilde file
okay
that's what we do now so that's the
algorithm the algorithm is just that you
take this polynomial system run the
degree 8 sum of squares sdp on it and
you will see what you get
for the linear function
okay and
this
algorithm
you know kothari clevens and mecca
show that this algorithm
[Music]
the l star the l star's error
on the on the good set
is at most uh
like the original error that we had like
delta plus square root of
epsilon
so
okay and but okay so but now let's see
okay so we've used it now how would you
see how how do we analyze
uh the sum of squares sdps how do we
analyze this
okay that that's our goal next
okay so let's see
so um
so so it turns out that the way to
think about the samosa's dps or uh
reason about them is to look at the dual
and the dual has a very nice object
which is the dual of the sum of squares
sdps or semi different program that
we're looking at are sum of squares
proofs
okay what is a sum of squares proof
well sum of squares proof is just a
proof system
to reason about polynomial system
inequalities
for example
suppose you had
the following set of inequalities with
you some if p i of x greater than equal
to 0 from i equal to 1 to m
and you want to prove that these
inequalities imply q of x is greater
than equal to 0.
okay you want to prove this and a very
natural proof
which you know it's like from some high
school algebra is to actually find an
identity
like this if suppose you found an
identity which looks like this q of x
is equal to
uh
sum over i
of a sum of squares polynomial
some sum of squares polynomial
times p i of x
plus another sum of squares polynomial
okay and what's a sum of squares
polynomial is just what it is it's a sum
of squares it's just r s squared of x
okay r i j squared but with some sum of
squares
so if you find an identity which looks
like this
this is an immediate certificate that q
of x is greater than equal to zero
whenever p i of x is greater than equal
zero for all i
this is a proof
and
so the dual of the semi sum of square
semi-definite program is really looking
for sum of squares proofs of polynomial
inequalities this way so in particular
to prove facts about
the pseudo expectation operator all you
need to do is to prove
sum of squares to find sum of squares
groups in particular here's the theorem
all right so
so e
tilde
like okay suppose
suppose
p tilde is a degree d pseudo expectation
function
the output of a degree d sum of squares
is dp then e tilde of q of x
is greater than or equal to zero
um
well let me just say state one one
direction implication right here uh if
you can prove p1 pi of x
greater than equal to 0
i 1 through m
1 through m
implies
q of x greater than or equal to 0
using degree d
if there is a degree d sum of squares
proof that these inequalities imply this
inequality
then
the corresponding pseudo expectation is
also greater than equal zero
okay
so if you want facts
well
basically pseudo expectation is talking
about pseudomoments there's a pseudo
momentum pseudo distribution if you want
to prove facts about the pseudo world of
pseudo moments and pseudo distributions
or whatever facts that are true there
the only only way to prove them is by
proving
uh the fact using a sum of squares
polynomials by sum of squares proofs
okay so let's see how this goes
an example would be good
um so
okay so let's say you want to prove that
w i is less than one okay and i've post
uh pasted the polynomial system that we
are using on the left
so this is our sort of our axioms of our
system
okay on which with which we start all
our proofs with and suppose you want to
prove this inequality w i less than 1
well here's a proof you could say
1 minus wi
is equal to 1 minus wi whole square
plus wi minus wi squared
okay just an identity and
this is an sos polynomial
and this is one of your
axioms
right so this is a proof that uh this is
greater than equal to zero so we proved
that one minus w is greater than zero
so what so this is just algebraic right
now this is just high school algebra
here but what what happened is because
of that we actually have
a conclusion now e tilde of wi is less
than one
okay
okay and then similarly you know if you
want to prove w is greater than or equal
to zero it's this is even easier you say
oh let's say look at w i is equal to w a
square and so therefore this is greater
than equal to zero
so therefore uh
okay
please talk to me if you have any
questions and so the real power of
summer squares uh sdps uh is that uh
it
you know it
it brings in all the power of high
school algebra you know inequalities the
way you can simplify just algebra
into analysis of sdps
right instead of thinking about vectors
and geometry now you're just doing high
school algebra to sort of simplify
things so it's very powerful
so let's see so suppose i want to
go back to what we wanted to do earlier
uh what did we want to do earlier we
want to understand the error on the good
points of the output linear function
remember that we output the linear
function e tilde of l
that was our output linear function so
let me write down what the error on the
good points is so for that it's actually
convenient to define some notation
so let w i hat
be
the
what is w a hat here it is the indicator
that x i is a good point
okay
okay so you have an indicator function
for x i being a good point so let's see
what is the error on the good points
well if you sum over all the i equal to
1 through n
and you say w i hat
times
y i minus
the thing that you output e tilde l this
is your function that you output
this is the error y i minus e tilde l x
i that's the error you square the error
and you sum it up over all the good
parts
okay so w i hat is an honest about 0 1
number it's just a definition
but l is a
variable and y i and x i are really also
numbers here
just to keep track of what's a variable
what's a number everything looks like a
variable here so okay so now um
so now you know how do we go about
simplifying this
well uh
the thing is you know don't our only
tool of at hand is sum of squares proof
so every step we do we have to justify
using the sum of squares proof okay but
uh so here's one fact about pseudo
expectations which you can prove using
uh sum of squares proof uh it's the
pseudo expectation taushi schwartz which
is e tilde of a polynomial squared
is at least
e tilde of the polynomial
whole squared
okay this is a pseudo expectation
schwartz um
you know this is just uh
you can you know
this is an ident inequality it's true
and
you uh let's take this for granted also
because you shorts inequality
if it's true expectation of course it's
true or should i expect you to prove
using a sum of squares proof and but you
can do it
okay so what that lets us do is
let's just it lets us move this pseudo
expectation in here
out
right so we just say this is at most
pseudo expectation
actually let's move it all the way out
sum over i equal to 1 through n
w i hat
y i minus
l inner product x i
whole squared
okay so that's good
all right so
so then okay so
uh what do we do next well
so
so you know the thing is it's going to
be an algebraic proof and we have to use
the axioms that we have
and
you know therefore let's just proceed
and see how to get get to our axioms
that we have so the thing i'll do is
i'll introduce
wi
plus 1 minus wi
in here in the middle
okay that's just some thing so i'll get
two terms now so i'll get term one which
is e tilde of
sum over i
w i hat
w i
times the error term y minus
l inner vertex i
the whole square and that's term 1 and
then there's another term which is
e tilde of
sum over i
w i hat 1 minus w i
times
y i minus
l in a product x i
the whole squared
okay i get two terms like this
okay so that's good uh
okay so now uh
let's just bound the two terms
separately one by one the first term is
i wrote down the first term here
and the first term is easy because
i mean recall that w i hat is a really a
number which is 0 or 1 which is
indicator of x is a good point okay
it's not a variable so in fact if i look
at this first line here there is a
number w i hat here which is zero or one
if i drop it
i'll only increase its value so i'll
just drop drop w i hat
if i drop w a hat i'll get a larger
value
okay
okay this is very nice why so because
now the second line here
this is exactly corresponds to one of
our axioms that we have
okay the axiom about what is the
total error on the good points that the
sdp
shows up
so it's really this is really one of the
axioms we have so therefore the second
line is really n times
eta i mean actually i
i've been
sort of a little bit
careless with my notation i should have
stuck with eta but
now i have delta delta is there so n
times that
so that's that's it
okay so this was easy term one is easy
term two is where something interesting
happens or something we have some little
bit of work to do
okay again what happened what's term two
the first step in term two is okay this
is a term two i drop
w i hat okay that's just because i know
w i hat is zero or one so if i you know
if i drop it i'll only increase the
value so i drop w i hat
okay so that was easy
okay the second step is i'm using
akaushi schwartz
okay so i'm going to use a kaushi
schwartz inequality
again i'm going to appeal to sudo
expectation gaussian shorts
inequality
and i get this
so
okay
please stop me if there's any questions
i haven't checked the
uh okay there are no other questions
okay
okay so this is what we need to bound i
applied acoustic force inequality okay
so so the first term summation over i 1
minus w i squared well what is that
you know
you can expand it out it's sum over i
1 minus w i
2 w i plus w i squared
ok and then you write it expand it out
this is exactly equal to epsilon n
okay
because of the this polynomial is
exactly equal to epsilon n because of
the constraints the axioms because just
because of axiom 1 and x m2 together
this just imply that
okay so it's really the second term
which is interesting
okay so what have what happens in the
second term
okay so in the second term first thing
i'll do
i will uh
maybe i'll just drop the wi
okay because
okay what do i need in order to drop wi
i need w i squared less than one right
yes
[Music]
oh right right yeah okay that's even
simpler thanks yeah
okay yeah that's what i should have done
yeah okay good
yeah
thanks yeah
yeah okay so that's yeah good okay so so
now you know we just need to bound the
second term
and uh
um
first thing we'll do is we'll just uh
use
the inequality
the simple inequality a plus b whole to
the 4 is smaller than 4 times a to the 4
plus 4 times b to the 4
right yeah 4 times a to the 4 plus 4
times b to the 4. so
that means that i can just expand this
out i get one over n
sum over i okay first thing is
uh
yeah all right
there's this little bit of subtlety here
which i should have been careful okay so
i didn't really drop the i so remember i
was sum was over all one through n
initially the sum was overall one
through n and then i don't really drop
wi i actually keep w i hat so i'm just
going to
write this as i or the good set s
because w i hat picks out really the
good good points so it's really the i o
of the good set
okay okay so now okay now what i what do
i have i have an average over the good
set
okay an average over the good set of y i
to the 4
plus
l in a product x i
to the 4
okay
is what i have
of course there's an e tilde here e
tilde here
okay this is what i have
so so the key point is it's an average
over the good set
okay because in average over the good
set
all the way random variables are very
well behaved in particular
uh capital x is a gaussian
y i is also a nice gaussian
right so in fact you can bound the
norm of all of these quantities here
right what is the um
the average over the good set average of
the good points of y to the 4 is like i
have taking a standard gaussian taking n
copies of it averaging it so the first
term is order one
okay
the second term is a little bit more
subtle because it's it's you're not
averaging a number you're averaging some
pseudo expectation but pseudo
expectation is linear so let's just talk
about the av
this quantity is a
pseudo expectation
of the average polynomial
okay what is the average polynomial
of uh
you know average of you know average
overall gaussian space let's say average
overall gaussian space of l in a product
x
whole to the four
so here what i did was i just replaced
the average over
and
the good set assume there's enough
samples i have lots of good points so
the as you replace the average over the
good set by average over the gaussian
space of this quantity you know if you
have sufficient sample that that won't
be a problem and then
what is this polynomial as a polynomial
this is actually equal to
normal
whole to the four sorry
three times normal hold to the floor
that's what that polynomial is like
exactly equal to
okay so
right so that's good so now we have uh
e tilde of three times normal whole to
the four
okay and we already assumed that normal
squared is less than one so like that's
part of our axioms
one of our axioms normal squared less
than 1 therefore this is at most
3.
okay so the whole thing
is you have
an epsilon to the half
times an order one quantity so you get
order square root epsilon
and the square root comes because of the
cushy shots
okay so that's that's the whole analysis
um
so
the key point that sort of i want to
drive is i guess there are two points um
one is of course that
you got the entire all the power of high
school algebra
uh into
analysis of an sdp which is very good
and the second thing is that
what we did over here
is also something conceptual in that
you know in some sense
if you had
a black box
that actually solved
polynomial systems like a like a
magical box that solved polynomial
systems
okay and then if you fed it the
polynomial system that we wrote down for
linear regression
write the polymer system that we wrote
for for linear regression
okay
then at least in the you know even at
least in that case
we should be able to prove that the
output is what we want right we want to
prove we'd have to prove that l star is
close to the true linear function
otherwise we did something wrong when we
wrote the linear polynomial system okay
so it should at least be true that the
polynomial system correctly identifies
the linear function okay this is
identification so of course you need to
prove this right and what what we just
saw is that if you prove identifiability
if you prove if the proof of
identifiability
is
a degree d sum of squared sum of squares
proof
then
is a degree sum of squares proof
uh
then the degree d so sdp works in
finding it
sdp finds the link
so that's the power of this so really in
some sense you you're doing what you
naturally have to do right you naturally
have to prove things
right
and all we're saying is you just tie
your hands and use a sum of squares
proof then your sdp also proves the same
thing internally and gives you the right
answer
okay so
any questions on that
okay so so this is a very powerful
paradigm it's been used in lots of
problems for robust
statistics
okay so that i think completes uh
um the discussion of uh or
the demo of one example of sum of
squares sdps uh that i wanted to show
hopefully you have a sense of uh
um what summer square rcps can do
um
so let's proceed further
so uh
okay so
the next thing i want to talk about is i
want to suggest
some open questions and research
directions broadly in this area in
algorithmics and
i think one of the very compelling
research direction actually is
to mix local and global algorithms
so this is a
what do i mean so firstly if you look at
local algorithms what are local
algorithms i would put bp amp
and
you know something even simpler like
what's a simpler one tree recursion
what's a tree recursion
well uh you know in stochastic block
model for example
if you had
let me show the tree regression thing is
i guess
what i mean is
in in stochastic block model
if i have a vertex and its neighborhood
looks like a tree
okay now suppose i told you the labels
of the
leaves of the tree
okay suppose i told you the
labels of the leaves of the tree then
there's an immediate base ruler you know
you can use or just a markov property
lets you figure out the marginal of the
root
right it's just very easy to figure out
much of the root so this i'm calling it
a tree recursion algorithm because it's
somehow there's some algorithmic thing
you have to do given the leaves you have
to compute the
root and it's a simple thing but still
some local thing
okay
so
these are local algorithms what i what
would i call a global algorithm is uh
spectral or sdp
okay so
um
what what are these well you know uh we
saw wind resorts for cloud
non-backtracking walk at sdp and the key
point here is that
here when we say bp i mean constant
number of iterations of bp
and this is uh of course
spectral analysis
okay so now
what is true well
the
typically we know how to show bp
converges or amp converges only when we
have constant correlation with the true
answer somehow in the neighborhood of
the true answer or with constant like if
you start at a at a warm start
where you start with constant
correlation with the true answer uh then
you have uh
then you can show that in constantly
many steps you get to the optimal answer
um
whereas spectre and sdp you know if you
look at spectral the way it works is you
use power method and you do power method
you start the random point
it's a random
starting point
or in some sense you don't need any
special starting point
it's a it's a full-fledged algorithm on
its own
okay so whereas
in the warm set you need to find the
warm star
okay and what is the
advantage of global
local algorithms well local algorithms
are really trying to
use all the
local probabilistic structure that is
there right in particular in this tree
and reconstruction
you really know exactly how the
nodes inside the tree should behave
given the neighborhood right and the
local algorithm will try to
you know respect that and figure out the
marginals based on the local rules right
so therefore it's somehow you could say
it's optimal it does sort of the optimal
thing to do in a neighborhood
okay whereas if you look at spectral or
sdp it it's uh very far from doing that
right it's um
um
you know it it like it has a
uh
you know it
it doesn't really it's not clear if it
doesn't something often locally so in
particular
it seems to me that seems to be that if
you want to solve
i guess one open question would be
how do you get
optimal recovery in svms
if you want to solve this it seems like
we have to mix local and global together
local and global would have to sort of
work together
um
right and uh so this in fact same
particular i guess of really completely
open questions to find do optimal
recovery in spm of course there's a
caveat here the caveat is that maybe
optimal recovery in sbm is actually hard
to do
but
you know maybe in some cases it's easy
and we'll even just get started on it it
seems very tricky
sorry
sorry the
optimality here is the probability of
error is optimal uh optim all right
optimal the pro the optimality is uh
the correlation with the true
planted community
yeah so you want to maximize the
correlation with the original planted
community that you had
uh
i'm sorry
two communities number of communities oh
right right yeah so i mean you would
start you want to start doing it for two
communities and for
greater number of communities there is a
chance that uh there are
uh
you know if a actually for even for two
communities a higher higher number of
communities it's not clear
if it should be completely tractable to
find the bayes optimal
uh solution but uh
um i mean it could be
uh
it could be computationally interactable
but uh
you know we are so far away from the
uh algorithm that we get don't see the
barriers
yet
right it's will i think
maybe we'll see the barriers if we go
closer but we are so far i don't think
we see the barriers here
okay so
um so i mean and and uh
like this research direction actually i
i i think
it sort of has implications even beyond
inference um like
even if you look at combinatorial
optimization
there are sort of open questions here
who which are all
related to this issue of how do you mix
local and global okay so what's the most
favorite problem in combinational
optimization max cut right so max cut we
know everything like you know it's point
eight seven eight well of course we
don't know the unique games conjecture
but um
so at least we know some things about
for max square so then you could ask
uh what about bounded degree max cut
so
can you get a 0.878
plus
order 1 over square root d
approximation
for max cut on degree d graph
meaning you want to beat 0.878 and in
fact you ideally would want to know how
much exactly we can beat uh like you
know for every d if i ask you what is
the best approximation for max cut on
degree five graphs hopefully we'll have
an answer to that someday but even the
order of magnitude where it's ordered
one over d is not known
and what is the issue here well the
issue is you run government's williamson
okay government sri lanka gives you
0.878
already once you run it you get 0.878
but because government syllabus is such
a global rounding algorithm it will make
mistakes
so there will be neighborhoods for
instance they'll be on obviously wrong
so there'll be a neighborhood where all
the neighbors are plus one
and the vertex will also be plus one
right there'll be all sorts of mistakes
in this
half space cut that we produce
okay
and a local algorithm will immediately
see the mistakes and try to fix it so
the obvious thing to do is run
government slim sun and fix it by hand
but then we don't know how to analyze it
and so it's sort of
stuck i think so i should say there is
work by phi gay uh i um
who gave an algorithm which is 0.878
plus 1 over d to the 4
for this problem and but order 1 over d
is sort of the reasonable answer here
because you can prove a hardness of
order one over d
um on dvd graphs by sampling
but in general if the this is
comes down to this issue how do you mix
local and global and you know there are
some other problems where you know
global algorithms have haven't made a
dent at all yet for example
three-dimensional matching
which is sort of uh related to
uni independent certain degree three
graphs it's not exactly the same but
it's
sort of related
um
for three dimensional matching again uh
the best algorithm is a four third
approximation uh using uh
using local search
uh and uh you know it's an it's an
interesting question to try to do it
using convex optimization i think it's
that might be doable
but
in general can you push
this frontier further
okay so what are the three what are the
different possibilities here well one
possibility is that maybe local just
subsumes global
okay so
the meaning you
you
show that bp actually just converges
from random initialization or it doesn't
even have to be random some
uh initialization that you can compute
easily
okay
in particular you know you'd hope that
bp is this sort of this update given the
neighbors you compute the root compute
the root uh so you hope that it can
simulate the power methods bp should be
able to simulate spectral
but
as but i think the
analyzing this for login steps is very
hard and uh
we don't have good ways to do this
um
okay so what is the other situation
the other situation is
oh yes do you know this here for sb
that oh no we don't know we don't know
this for any of the models yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah and uh
the same okay they could across the
reverse question maybe okay global
subsumes local
okay so global substance local is uh uh
you know it seems
okay it seems like it should be true
well you know after all uh anything that
happens local is a low degree polynomial
so why don't we just encode all of the
local constraints the base optimality
local base optimality as
polynomials in our sos dp and try to run
it
so you know we can of course add all the
local constraints local optimality
local base optimality into the sources
dp and you can write an ssdp that way of
course but the issue is we don't know
how to analyze it
um i guess but there's one success on
this front
when global is assuming local uh it's
it's not from uh inference but in
optimization combinatorial optimization
uh bansal gupta and guru ganesh they
showed that if you share adam's
hierarchy
plus sdp
you can use that to sort of get the
optimal
approximation for
degree d independent set independent
certain degree d class
okay you can do that but uh we don't
uh but but you know the proof involved a
lot of
um
really using a
lot of results from graph theory um so
on so
so we still don't know basically how to
make global subsuming local in any of
the contexts that i'm you know
stochastic block model or optimization
okay the more viable approach may be
okay first you use a global algorithm
and then you use it to get a local
then you that the output of the global
algorithm becomes the input to a local
algorithm
okay and
this has been done in a few place a few
times and in fact basically the global
algorithm gives you like a warm start
for your bp or something and then local
and one thing
the key difficulty here is
you know one of the key difficulties
here with using with bp is the following
that the output of the global algorithm
is not a probabilistic object
right output of global suppose you run
spectral method
and you get the eigenvector and you
round it somehow so you have some vector
plus minus one vector
you have very little information
probabilistically about that vector
apart from the globally it's correlated
with the true solution you don't know
anything locally about its pro how the
probability distribution behaves
so basically
you start at a point where you know very
little about what's going on and the and
the worst is that you somehow used up
all the randomness already because the
global algorithm already looked at the
whole graph and computed the eigenvector
so for a local algorithm there's no
randomness left to sort of play with or
like
sort of nothing looks random or
probabilistic for the local algorithm
um but you know
this issue was handled cleverly in this
paper most of the even slide so what
they did was the following so
what what they do is
so you have a sbm
okay
um
for every vertex for every vertex you in
the sbm you pluck out a tree
of some depth
let's say this t sub view is a tree
okay
what you do is you you run the spectral
algorithm
on the graph minus the tree
okay
after you run the spectral item on the
graph minus the tree you do get a plus
minus one cut
and it's not a probabilistic object
there's no
nice product distribution on it but one
thing is true is that the plus minus one
values is globally correlated with the
true solution so you get a cut x on
on the vertices of g minus t u
right
uh that is correlated with the true cut
right x in a product x hat the true with
the true cut the correlation is like i
don't know 0.9 or let's say 1 minus 1
minus beta
okay there's some
correlation with the true cut
okay and now
the clever ideas
because we did not use
the tree at all
the spectral algorithm did not even see
the tree local tree
the randomness in the tree is still
there with us
in particular
you can think of the places where u
connects to the graph
as a random thing because it was this
graph is an spm so in particular the way
the
to sample a neighborhood of you is you
start drawing growing a tree around you
just like we saw yesterday like poisson
tree galton watson tree and then it's
going to attach to this graph g minus t
u at some random location
okay it's random from the point of view
of the spectral algorithm in particular
what that means is you're back to
in some sense locally in this tree
the situation looks like the tree
reconstruction that we just saw
okay
it looks like tree reconstruction
with all the leaves
uh having some noise in them the noise
coming because your spectral algorithm
is not perfect it's going to have some
noise so therefore therefore it looks
like noisy tree reconstruction
and what mozzarella are able to do is
they're able to show that noisy tree
reconstruction
is just as good as true tree
reconstruction
if you are sufficiently above the case
threshold
so sufficiently above the case threshold
this gives an optimal recovery
in base optimal recovery so it's a very
nice algorithm so there is a another
reference which i wanted to add here
um
hopefully someone in the audience can
tell me the reference itself paper by
montanari and
someone i'm missing um on in the context
of amp they have uh
um
an algorithm which is globe first global
then local
okay yeah so
so but this seems like a more viable
approach but the key bottleneck here is
as i said the global object is not
probabilistic
okay so
[Music]
that's good let me
um
so
so
from from
like
okay um so let
so let me um
move on so here the next thing i want to
mention i want to mention a couple of
open questions um in sum of squares
lower bounds uh the first logan question
is uh to prove a sharp transition in the
refutation complexity
right so we have lower bonds for sos for
planted clique
we also have nice lower bonds for uh
many problems i guess uh 3 xr and so on
but
i guess some of those transitions are
not sharp
so
this is one of the sharp transitions
which i'm
quite interested in so here the issue
the the setup is you're given a graph
which is erdogan
graph with average degree d
okay and you want to
certify the size on the max such as the
maximal independent set of this graph
and
you of course you can use degree sum of
squares to certify
and you know if you define
alpha d
to be
the optimum
of
degree d
sos sdp
for max independent set
okay so this is basically the best bound
that the degree d sum of squares sdp can
certify i guess i didn't mention that
is the average vp related to this degree
the sos
oh sorry thanks yeah
i should say so yeah thanks thanks yeah
it's alpha l is the degree l sum of
squares is yeah thanks
yeah i fixed the degree d in the graph
and asked for alpha l as i vary l uh i
get better and better bounds and one
thing i didn't mention earlier is that
degree l s o s dp takes n to the l time
so in some sense the degree of the sum
of squares is ep is suit a proxy for
complexity of the problem so then you
could plot
how this
like this upper bound that you certify
does it improve as you increase the
increase l increase the degree of the
source
and
basically already
alpha 2
alpha 2 is some value
and
the
point is that the value
you'd expect or if you believe that
there's a sharp transition we expect
that the value doesn't budge at all
until you
increase your degree of your sum of
squares scp to something super constant
like log n in particular the open
question is that
can you prove or is it true that
alpha 2 is equal to alpha 100
or more generally
alpha 2 is equal to alpha l for all and
natural numbers
for all fixed l is the case that the
value doesn't budge at all this is a
this would be a sharp transition in the
complexity of certifying an upper bound
on the independent set
so um
and that'll be nice
i mean
i think there are very few results where
you have such a sharp transition i guess
one such result is the i think the
recent result on sherrington kirkpatrick
where you can show that
two you know certificate any bound
bigger than two is hard
but here is another one which
interesting
okay and the other uh i guess one of my
favorite questions is to
uh prove a lower bound for local
statistics plus society like the local
studies sdp that i mentioned yesterday
with their sos sdp for bayesian csps in
particular yesterday we saw this
transition
where the problem is supposed to go from
easy to hard meaning whenever we have a
stable
whenever the knife fixed point is stable
we believe that the problem becomes hard
right so
here's a question when the knife fixed
point is stable prove that
local statistics
plus sossdp
is feasible even on random graphs
in the null distribution
so meaning that the local statistics as
dp which is sort of the natural sdp that
achieves the
it's a natural ship that achieves the
threshold doesn't uh
um
cannot distinguish just below the
threshold
okay
and this will be i think this is this
will be a very good evidence i think for
uh this
change in complexity that we've been
conjecturing yesterday we drew all these
pictures and now we know the region
where the problems are easy and are real
and
we have it'd be nice to gather evidence
that the problems are hard when it's
supposed to be hard and i think this is
one
good way to
show that the complexity of the problem
does change drastically when you cross
that transition
for example two community sbm or sorry
the k community sbm once you cross the
cast institution threshold at the
customs threshold you don't approve this
and here of course uh
you know this is looks like an ssdp
lower bound question but it's actually
also i mean i i could also state it as a
question which is uh
maybe interesting
from a different point of view
you know the
there's a natural
measure on like there's a natural choice
of marginals at a bp fixed point the
natural choice of marginals are given by
this
it's the bette state or this net like
that at a bp fixed point
for any local marginal there's a natural
answer
this bethe stater
basically if you give me any tree for
example
i can write down the marginal
distribution of the labels here because
i know all the incoming messages to the
tree i can write down the so bp
in short bp uh recommends a set of
marginals bp recommends how the
distribution should look like locally
okay and
this this distribution
kind of satisfies most of the constraint
that you would want
the only thing that's hard to prove of
course is that
this set of marginals recommended by the
bp is actually positive semi-definite
so basically the beth state the bethe
measure uh
the
local marginals of the beta measure that
you can calculate
you want to prove that
that is pst
and there is hope here because
um i i think uh
siddhanth somebody verified that he told
me that um
the
beth states
are the better measure that you get here
coincides with the solution that's
recommended by pseudo calibration which
is a different technique for proving sap
lower bonds
so there is a natural answer for what
the sdp solution should be to prove this
lower bond
and we
we just need to prove that that solution
works
okay
any questions
um in the problem of certifying an upper
bound for a max independent set
um
what is the conjecture value of alpha
where we get stuck
i think
i think alpha two is like one over
square root d
and maybe i'm
yeah i think i think it's 1 over square
root of b
incredibly i have the exact same
question
questions with one stone
just just
just to see if you have uh perspective
for large d the true answer is
much smaller or the magnitude two log d
over d and so you're saying alpha two is
one over root d
yes that's
okay
yeah yeah and you know one over root d
comes from spectral right basically you
know uh
yeah
this this conjecture says that you can't
do better than the naive spectral
like alpha two is one over square root
of t
one level t is the gaussian wave
function so then for max cut it probably
gives a better approximation
it's it's it's just not not well suited
for independence it's probably most
comparison
right also this is oh yeah
that's right
yeah i mean i think also the issue is
certification right the um certifying an
upper bound is different than finding
one i think that's the key difference
here
any other questions
well i have a question prasad can you
hear me yes that's
hey great great presentation i i
actually wanted to ask you in in the
analysis
for the um robust progression yeah
there's there's some there's some point
during the analysis
i can't remember where this happens and
i didn't quite see it in your analysis
where you have to assume that epsilon
the fraction of corrupted points
um is is bounded you know has to be
bounded less than some constant or the
whole argument breaks
and then what happens is
if you want to kind of extend this to
um higher degree like regression for
higher degree polynomials then that
constant
of fraction of errors that you can
handle gets smaller and smaller and sort
of an exponentially bad way
it's sort of annoying and so i know like
if you want to get around that for
linear regression
you can use these techniques that we've
both worked on for you know the list
decodable case but i was just wondering
is there some
simple
analysis that can handle all values of
eta you know less than i mean
sorry like oh like you know basically
basically all values of epsilon less
than like a half i think a half is the
limit here
something like that so sorry for the
technical question i don't know
yeah i guess we shouldn't expect it
right because we should expect to be
able to produce a list right
um as an e tilde l for instance could be
zero the the we need to change the
rounding somehow to make this for this
to work now even if i'm saying even if
epsilon is less if epsilon is less than
a half then you should always be able to
get a unique one
yes yes uh but but you're saying that
this analysis doesn't even reach yeah
yeah like it needs to be less than you
know some small constant
and then it gets worse as you as you go
up to higher degrees oh okay i actually
i didn't we haven't looked into that at
all yeah yeah i haven't thought about it
yeah
okay sorry yeah thanks yeah great great
talk
excellent so i guess let's take a 20
minute break we'll be back here at 3 25
and thanks again percent
oh